you I hate that phrase of oh she's the
one you complete me people ask me that
sometimes how didd you know she was the
one well she wasn't the one I mean it's
not like there's one person out there of
the 8 billion people there's just one
out there who was designed spe specially
for you and it's written in the stars
and you have to find that one person
that's not the way it works you don't
find the one person you find a person oh
pick me pick me who you line up with in
this way and then they become the one
when you say I do when you get married
you know so it's like you get
married not because this person is the
one they become the one when you marry
them and that that's what makes the
marriage vows so powerful